um all right i think so so i put up a
video last night and someone was upset
as usual with my physics because people
are always upset about everything um
because apparently what happens is when
i shoot this thing
it doesn't really apply the physics
correctly because when i shoot it what
i'm actually doing is every one of these
pieces
that's crumbling right every one of
those pieces uh
it like gets the velocity of where i of
where it got hit right so if i shoot it
that way you can see it actually goes
that way
but i think what they're saying is that
well what happens to the fact that it
was traveling downwards like why does
that suddenly disappear and i kind of
agree with that
so let's try and play with the scripting
a little bit but we can see
we can try and and make the physics a
little bit more realistic
or like at least not completely ignore
the fact that it had a downwards
velocity so we have cube spawn and that
an orange cube so this is so fracture
and it gets an impulse and it
yeah okay
so and then fracture i guess gets called
probably from
cube spawn on a orange cube well where's
the actual
that doesn't do it
oh no no this
creates the pieces i see
so when this does this um and where does
this get called
from oh from the player i think no yeah
because the player can fracture because
it flashes when it hits the ground but
then if i shoot
here as you can see then i'm also
uh getting the orange cube entity here
and then i fracture it with the
direction of the bullet so what i
probably should do here is not
completely ignore
um
the downwards velocity right
so and i can probably stop logging all
of this
some other rigid body well other rigid
body we can do that with but so
yeah because it spawns a new entity so
we should probably give it an initial
thing
so but but see the thing is though we're
not like ah but we spawn in the
fractured pieces
so fracture spawns this stuff in
so what we probably should do
because this is orange cube
is we should probably get
ah this does all the children here when
we get this and we have the force
we should probably set the initial like
velocity
so linear velocity equal to our orange
cube's linear velocity
right so that would be
do we have rigid body in here
uh let's do that here so we'll do
a rigid body
component
rigid body and then we'll uncreate we'll
do rigid body get component
rigid body component
and then
[Music]
maybe i'll do that first and then
we'll do
rigid body dot linear velocity so we're
actually copying the linear velocity
from the original orange cube into this
new thing let's not maybe do this yet
just so that we can validate that it
remains the same i guess
actually let's validate a couple things
so let's let's get rid of this
as well so it's just going to spawn in
the cubes they're going to be like doing
nothing basically
so
let's shoot this
yeah so you can see we have a pause when
we do that
can i just like spawn in more cubes or
something
making spawn faster
yeah so you can see that it kind of like
pauses because it reduces to zero so our
goal is going to be
see if we have that pause we might want
to click on it our goal is going to be
no pause so this should give us no pause
yeah you can see it didn't even look
like i clicked on it click
no pause
yeah i'm just clicking on it you can see
the orange thing appear
click
and that's it
so but now we have no pause but now we
also add in that impulse so that way
it's not like we reset the linear
velocity linear velocity to zero we're
not doing that anymore
and it should be better
i guess that looks better but now i feel
like we need more of an impulse
so i mean it does
well actually so we get a random impulse
between what zero and one here
well that's just supposed to get the
vector to be different but we have an
original impulse that gets set from
[Music]
the player
so it's regarding times eight so i think
that this can be also something that we
get a random thing from so
that's system random i don't really want
to use that hazel random float
so hazel random float float force equals
hazelnut and float times
five plus
six
i don't know
so that'll give us a random number
between like six and 11 which maybe
we'll do six plus six
times force
so this will be a little bit of a
more advanced force now i think peter
did add some explosive force if we
wanted to actually explode from the
inside but i kind of like this mechanic
i'll play with the controller
but i still kind of feel like it's not
it doesn't have enough force
[Music]
or maybe because like
maybe i don't know from my i've made
them i made a lot more spawn
but i don't know maybe i just liked the
because their linear velocity is kind of
linear velocity isn't isn't nothing you
know maybe maybe we shouldn't
let's just make it be really excessively
high because now we're kind of
accounting for the linear velocity as
well
yeah that's pretty
it's like a rocket launcher
you can see it goes pretty far
i don't know
see this is what i mean like maybe this
is more physically accurate but from a
gameplay point of view
you know i kind of liked how it was
it just felt cooler
so what did we change exactly we changed
this so if we don't do the copying of
the linear velocity
then even though it doesn't really it's
not as real
it's just that just looks cooler to me
doesn't it
because it feels like your bullet is
kind of just stops it maybe we could
just like get the linear velocity but
like half it or something
so we have like the best of both worlds
a bit of a mix
that that's kind of cool
we could also just make it be a little
bit more explosive
so
we get a random impulse of one
and we add that to m because yeah
because we want to have
some
variation
but what does this do so this gives us a
max
0.5 so we could if we set it to 2 it'll
be 1 minus 1
because at the moment it's between like
negative 0.5 and positive 0.5
which might not be that great
but we could make it
because this is two
but this is one
so what is this fracture and fracture so
this this is the player fracturing yeah
i probably should be too
that gives it a little bit more of like
variation or whatever
[Music]
yeah that's i think that looks nicer
and yeah like if you wanted it to be
more explosive you could definitely
modify this by the way
like if we did two plus hazel
random float
um
oh that already is random
never mind
this already is random but the amount
yeah we could definitely increase the
amount right so
um where am i keep losing everything
cube spawn why am i back and keep
spawner
orange cube is what i want so if we make
this like four
then it's just gonna increase the amount
of force
in a random direction see
which looks kind of cool
but yeah you know we could obviously
still randomize this doesn't matter like
we could we could do like hazel random
uh
float and then we could go up to four
you know because that way it would be
um it could be like a little weak
break or it could be like a strong one
you know
and that again just helps to add
variation
get rid of the grid
oh man there's so many
i think there's a bit of a cooldown as
well so we can't just like we have to
all right now uh if we wanted to be
really cool
we could add a little model for the gun
so that this is really beginning to be
an fps now i have this severus here
we're not going to use this definitely
and we should model like some hands but
if i just drag in the cerberus i'll make
it a static mesh and
sure
now it's quite big
it's going to have to be tiny
we probably don't want it to like cast
shadows and stuff
but we'll we'll take a look at it in a
minute um so let's grab this cerberus
model and let's drag it into player and
i guess into camera
so camera has that reticle yeah so
uh let's drag it into camera
and unless zero zero zero
um
so this is i guess our starting location
if we just take a look at
the physics colliders yeah so this is
what our player looks like oh wow he's
like in the ground why is he so big kind
of looks big
let's start him on top of this mountain
actually
and then you can see the cerberus let's
just shift it forward
yeah that's the right axis but it's
i think it's a bit too small
and we probably want to like
put it here or something
there we go
now it's an fps
this looks so bad hey guys check out my
fps
so we need some hands and stuff probably
but like we also want to have some
shake and some animation for it right
that's also a big a big problem that we
don't have
and i guess we probably want to maybe
rotate it ever so slightly
so it's a little bit more like
[Music]
maybe like facing that way
i like the specular
highlights on it looks cool
but yeah see easy
and i'm telling you guys the only reason
it looks like garbage is literally
because it's not moving like animation
is such a big deal
um
and like you don't need like skeleton
skeletal animation would be great but
you don't even need that and the shadow
okay let's man these shadow settings
these shadow settings are set up for
like the editor camera where you're like
100 meters in the air like they're not
set up for like being on the ground and
stuff so it's kind of frustrating
to be honest but like i mean this
probably isn't going to look that great
either because it's like it's such a
small model
because it's so close to the camera um
but we probably wouldn't have it casting
a shadow realistically and like clipping
through the floor and stuff that's a bit
weird
um
but yeah i think we've already
exhausted our cubes
yeah the cube delay is not enough so
let's go to the cube spawner
amount 100 delay one second
i think those are some decent settings
no i think this feels pretty good like
in terms of the cubes
somehow i didn't get that one
okay let's try and get
to the thing get to the chopper
well
okay i think we're seeing some frame
drops now
yeah that looks sick i like that it
looks really cool from a distance when
you shoot them
now we just need some particles like
some particle systems obviously some
sound effects
definitely a better controller for like
um well a better
like the gun should when you move the
gun should also kind of move a bit
so we need some nice like lurping and
some spherical
some slurping
for the rotations and whatever
but yeah cube hunt going well
and then yeah i'm really looking forward
to i'm probably gonna do that like
maybe like monday or something maybe not
monday
but
um i'm definitely gonna do the uh
i'm going to do instance rendering
um
all that kind of fun stuff instance
rendering and direct rendering
everything
all right sick
so yeah
what do you guys think happy
are you happy oh zeppyfrags thanks for
the sub didn't even notice yo i'm
downloading 2042 and stream is lagging
that's that's upsetting i was thinking
of getting 2042
battlefield um but
yeah maybe soon
maybe soon